thanks to brilliant for keeping legal
eagle in the air get 20% off your annual
subscription by using the link in the
description on March 11 2020 the World
Health Organization declared kovat 19 a
pandemic whu-oh has been assessing this
outbreak around-the-clock kovat 19 can
be characterized as a pandemic this
virus is not only making people sick but
it's appending our daily lives that
includes canceling vacations postponing
events and uh pending employment did you
plan a wedding that now needs to be
postponed did you have to cancel your
European vacation after the travel ban
is your small business suddenly behind
on rent well today we're gonna talk
about how you might be able to use
contract law and insurance agreements to
get refunds and even relief now let me
start with a disclaimer that probably
goes without saying but I'm going to say
it because I'm a lawyer nothing in this
video should be construed as legal
advice and nothing I say creates an
attorney-client relationship with you
the viewer if you have a coronavirus
related question you should contact your
own lawyer or better yet your doctor now
with that out of the way I do want to
give you one more warning what I'm going
to tell you is incredibly powerful but I
want you to use this information wisely
let's say you had a wedding scheduled
for April and maybe that won't be
happening now so naturally you're gonna
want to cancel with the caterers the
band the photographer but remember those
are people too that's how they make
their living and it's going to be hard
times ahead for those people everyone in
the service industry is going to suffer
a photographer can't work from home no
one's going to be hiring bands for
parties that won't be happening for the
foreseeable future unless you live in
Florida but it might be the same with
your landlord sure your apartment
building might be part of a giant
conglomerate owned by Blackrock but it
also might be the only building owned by
a family there are always downstream
consequences so sure no one's going to
blame you for having to look out for
yourself but remember that your actions
affect others too and everyone is going
to be struggling for the foreseeable
future
so with that business out of the way
today we're going to be covering such
sexy legal topics as terms and
conditions force majeure and insurance
writers oh yeah
[Music]
so let's start with the basics when you
make a reservation when you buy plane
tickets or you purchase anything on the
internet you agree to abide by certain
terms and conditions you can find out
what you agree to by clicking on the
terms and conditions page of most
websites or reviewing whatever document
they sent you by email or snail mail
this document contains all the legalese
that you didn't review and merely
glanced at at best and unfortunately
this is generally a binding contract
that applies to you the good news is
that you can learn to think like a
lawyer to help yourself out of a jam
often using the exact same language that
you find in those pages of text that you
absolutely did not read don't try and
fool anyone you didn't read it now if
you made travel reservations you should
immediately review the terms and
conditions pages to see what terms
applied originally and whether that
company has updated their policies
because of the coronavirus for example
air B&B is the original Travel disrupter
and they disrupted the travel industry
by creating a website that lets people
rent out their homes and extra rooms to
travelers
now generally Airbnb allows their hosts
to set their own cancellation policy
some hosts require a deposit and more
than 48 hours notice to cancel other
hosts are more strict taking the guest
deposit if the person cancels for any
reason but that changed on March 14th
when Airbnb notified hosts and guests
that was updating their extenuating
circumstances policy the site now allows
all guests to cancel all reservations
without penalty anywhere in the world as
long as the reservation for the travel
was between March 14th and April 14th
and as things go on and potentially get
worse that policy may be updated again a
lot of hosts are very unhappy with this
result since many depend on the income
to afford rent or pay for their mortgage
but if you're a guest however you might
be able to cancel your reservation then
monitor the host to ensure that they
comply with Airbnb snoo policy it's
really important not only to check the
original terms but also if anything has
been updated Business Insider has
compiled a list of hotels which have
updated their cancellation policies and
I'll put the link to that down in the
description below many hotels run by
groups like Disney Hilton and height are
waiving cancellation fees for travel
booked through April and if you have
travel dates that are later in the year
you might want to jump on the phone
immediately because you know things are
bad when travel companies are
voluntarily relaxing their contractual
terms and if the customer service people
are giving you a hard time one pro tip
is to use the government warnings to
your advantage for example the w-h-o the
World Health Organization declared
coronavirus a pandemic and experts are
unsure for how long extreme measures
like social distancing isolation and
Quarantine will last the State
Department has issued travel advisories
and warnings for certain countries state
governors have prohibited gatherings and
are locking down huge swathes of people
and when you're talking to customer
service you can cite these warnings as
evidence as to why you cannot travel and
should get a refund and we'll go into
detail about these specific legal
doctrines that you might use to
bootstrap some of these warnings in
dealing with customer service or other
companies that you might have to cancel
in order to get a refund now not all
travel or commercial companies are going
to be as gracious as the ones that are
voluntarily rolling back their
cancellation policies but if you dig
into the terms and conditions you might
find specific language or fine print
that says something along the lines of
the company is not responsible for any
injury loss or damage to person or
property death delay or inconvenience in
connection with the provision of any
goods or services occasioned by or
resulting from but not limited to and
this is the important part acts of God
or force majeure and that brings us to
one of the most important legal
doctrines that you're probably going to
be dealing with in this particular
situation acts of God and force majeure
now force majeure is basically like a
magic spell used by dark wizards called
lawyers force majeure I'm just kidding
it's a very dry contractual provision in
most circumstances but in circumstances
like these it can be just as powerful
because most contracts include a force
majeure clause these clauses excuse a
party from performing its obligations
under the contract if they are faced
with circumstances beyond that parties
control the phrase force majeure is
French for superior force the kind of
superior force that would interfere with
the performance of contracting and that
includes Wars labor disputes and extreme
weather events generally the test for
whether something is a force majeure
event requires three specific elements
number one the
is beyond the control of the affected
party to the affected parties ability to
perform it's part of a contract must
have been prevented impeded or hindered
by the event and three the affected
party must have taken all reasonable
steps to avoid or mitigate the event or
its consequences there are two
categories of force majeure events the
first category is for acts of government
that changed the legal or political
environment that could impact a project
or business this could include things
like war terrorism labor strikes or
rights
the second category includes natural
disasters such as floods earthquakes
hurricanes and other weather
disturbances there are sometimes called
acts of God when a party is affected by
a force majeure they are usually
relieved from performing the contract
there may be disputes about whether that
person's contractual obligations are
cancelled or just postponed now there's
no general statute that defines what
constitutes a force majeure event a
party's ability to claim relief for a
force majeure event depends on the way
that the contractual terms are written
in the context of the rest of the
contract most contracts contain a
detailed list of events that are deemed
to be force majeure and beyond the
parties control some contracts include
things like diseases pandemics or
epidemics in their list of naturally
occurring events that may disrupt a
contract however if a contract clause
omits language about diseases and
pandemics then there will probably be a
dispute about whether a pandemic like
corona virus is included in a force
majeure event for example if the
contract lists a bunch of categories
that do constitute a force majeure then
the fact that a pandemic is not listed
and it could be evidence that a pandemic
is not covered if there is vague
language that says that a force majeure
can be anything like an example of the
things that are given then you have a
better argument but there's no federal
law that says these particular things
are considered force majeure but if you
are looking through your own contractor
your own terms and conditions here's a
couple examples of what force majeure
clauses look like so you'll know what to
look for
notwithstanding anything to the contrary
contained herein neither party shall be
liable for any delays or failures in
performance resulting from acts beyond
its reasonable control including without
limitation acts of God acts of war or
terrorism shortage of supply brake
downs or malfunctions interruptions or
malfunction of computer facilities or
loss of data due to power failures or
mechanical difficulties with information
storage or retrieval systems labor
difficulties are civil unrest
notwithstanding the foregoing in the
event of such an occurrence each party
agrees to make a good faith effort to
perform its obligations here under so
would coronavirus be a force majeure
event under this clause well this is why
lawyers are going to outlive everyone
except the cockroaches because lawyers
will argue that the acts of God language
operates as a catch-all with respect to
events which are beyond the control of
the parties to the contract since a
pandemic would be beyond the reasonable
clinch control of the parties it seems
like the coronavirus crisis would be a
force majeure event under this type of
clause but you can also argue that since
it's not mentioned there perhaps it
doesn't cover that or that the actual
loss of business is not related to the
coronavirus per se but because of acts
of other people who are not going to
various businesses you can go either way
on some of these things but statements
like the whu-oh declaring coronavirus a
pandemic is certainly helpful to
consumers who want to make their case as
are the statements of various state
governors who are putting entire states
on lockdown so in a situation like this
you can argue that this is a change in
circumstances of the law that makes
performance impossible and you can also
argue that it is a natural event like a
plague or some other weather events such
as a natural disaster that would also be
covered by a force majeure clause there
their arguments for both sides and keep
in mind that making this argument of a
force majeure event doesn't necessarily
mean that the party themselves need to
test positive for coronavirus what we're
looking for here are disruptions that
are the direct result of coronavirus
like a forced self-isolation or shutting
down a factory these are the
consequences that impact a party's
ability to fulfill its contractual
obligations so for example think about
all the vendors that were providing
services to Miami's Ultra Music Festival
despite the festival taking place in
Florida where apparently anything goes
and there are no laws the festival was
actually cancelled after Florida's
governor declared a state of emergency
that allows us to create a unified
command structure it also allows if need
be
at a state medical personnel to operate
in Florida since the event was canceled
due to events beyond their control most
vendors should be able to rely on their
contracts force majeure language to
justify not performing the services
under the contract and if money changed
hands I would expect that that money
would change hands again and go back to
the original buyer but this isn't a
silver bullet it doesn't work all the
time for example if we're talking about
financial agreements like an investor's
contract to fund the start up a force
majeure event may not excuse investors
from making payments that they agreed to
make under a contract this is what
happened in the 2008 financial meltdown
which resulted in many lawsuits about
whether the financial crisis was a
qualifying event for force majeure
purposes most courts interpreted force
majeure clauses very narrowly market
forces didn't count as a force majeure
unless the specific financial scenario
was spelled out in the clause some
people also unhappily discovered that
market forces were directly excluded by
the contract as an excuse for
non-performance
that surely resulted in a lot of angry
phone calls to the parties lawyers which
you know keeps us employed to but force
majeure clauses are not a
get-out-of-jail-free card they don't
normally operate to excuse a party from
making rent payments operating expenses
or loan payments but in a situation like
this with a once-in-a-century pandemic
all bets are off lawyers are going to be
arguing over these clauses until we die
which you know for some of us maybe
pretty soon but force majeure is not the
only argument available to consumers and
people that are trying to get out of a
contract or not pay something if a
pandemic isn't included in the contract
or isn't interpreted to be in the
contract then parties might have to rely
on other defenses that excuse them from
performing under American law the
defenses of frustration and
impossibility may apply these defenses
are usually interpreted narrowly and
they usually require two considerations
number one whether the subject matter of
the contract or the means of performance
has been destroyed such that performance
is rendered objectively impossible and
to whether the essential purpose of the
contract has been frustrated or the
contract has become radically different
from what was contemplated by the
parties at the time that they
read on the terms many US states have
adopted the Uniform Commercial Code or
you CC the UCC applies when you buy a
good generally speaking and the UCC
includes an excuse where performance has
been made quote impracticable by the
occurrence of an event quote the non
occurrence of which was a basic
assumption on which the contract was
made so sorry for the double negative
but in other words something that the
contract assumed wouldn't happen this
defense might work in a scenario where a
state governor has canceled an event
because it would be attended by more
than 50 people if the event that needed
to occur was a gathering of thousands of
people such as those attending a music
festival then arguably the inability of
people to gather in a group because it
was made illegal could justify non
performance as impracticable which takes
me to the sexiest legal topic of all I
saved the best for last
insurance policies now if a party to a
contract can't meet its obligations do
the corona virus outbreak you probably
need to find out if insurance will cover
your losses some times it will and many
commercial property insurance policies
provide business interruption coverage
but companies covered by these policies
won't be able to invoke them unless they
can show direct physical loss to
property of the insured its customers or
its suppliers commercial insurers also
sell specific products dealing with
force majeure political risk insurance
or trade disruption insurance and
sometimes a policy that would otherwise
cover these things have what's called a
rider which excludes the specific
occurrence of things you'll often see
like a terrorism Rider that if your
store was bombed by a terrorist then the
insurance doesn't apply in that
particular case so you have to check not
only the policy itself but the riders
that go along with the policy if you
were an individual you might check your
homeowners insurance you might check
your renters insurance hell you might
try your car insurance because consumers
also have insurance implications to
consider many travelers buy travel
insurance to protect them from things
like a deadly pandemic that restricts
travel but if you think that your
insurance company does have you covered
you may be disappointed because
insurance companies are terrible once
again you have to look to the fine print
and this is frankly just always
advice many travel insurance companies
exclude health epidemics or pandemics in
their standard policies they won't even
refund travelers who are afraid to
travel because of the virus if you plan
to go later in the year you might buy a
policy that has a cancel for any reason
clause
however some insurance companies are
already limiting the number of cancel
for any reason policies that they're
going to sell in this environment now
that is largely the bad news but let me
give you some good news it looks like
help for small businesses is on the way
it's going to depend on what federal
relief is passed by Congress and state
laws will vary state by state but
everyone is on board to try and help out
as many people as possible now I can't
go into detail about all of these
different relief laws mainly because
they don't yet exist the debate is going
on in Congress but the good news is that
it seems like everyone is on board with
trying to help as many people for as
long as possible because really we only
recently realized how serious this whole
coronavirus thing is and if you want to
see my prior video on how the US
government has botched its a response
that coronavirus I'll leave link to the
descriptions of my prior video on the
subject no I don't take responsibility
at all but as you know if you own a
small business the coronavirus is
probably already disrupting your ability
to stay open and pay your employees many
restaurants are expected to close for
the duration of the lockdown and some
states have shut down tattoo parlors
nail salons restaurants and yes even
games stop any non-essential company is
being shut down this means that many
businesses are going to struggle to
survive and it's clear that the federal
government is trying to get its act
together and trying to help people it's
just not clear when that relief is going
to happen there's tremendous spirit to
get something done so we'll see what
happens so you might have to look to
your state and local governments for
help for example New York City Mayor
Bill de Blasio announced that the city
is offering no interest loans to
businesses which see sales decreased by
25 percent or more to qualify a business
must have fewer than 100 employees for
businesses with less than five workers
the city is offering grants to help
cover 40 percent of payroll costs and
this hopefully will help people stay
employed during the duration
of this pandemic and similarly Seattle
mayor Jenny Durkin will increase funds
available for micro businesses to help
small companies access SBA loans provide
relief for utility payments and the city
is also delaying collection of business
and occupation taxes at the federal
level we are starting to see
mobilization of the administrative state
the Small Business Administration has an
economic injury disaster loan program
that will give low-interest loans to
small businesses and nonprofits that
have been severely impacted by the
coronavirus and hopefully this will just
be the tip of the iceberg I expect a
whole raft of new and exciting statutory
laws that will help people in this
situation and all of the fund litigation
that's going to come as a result of it
but of course this is a constantly
evolving situation although we're
focused on the next four to six weeks
the reality is that quarantine isolation
and self isolation may last for a lot
longer than that and of course the
longer everyday life is disrupted the
greater economic impact of all the
businesses and contracts but if there's
one takeaway from all of this it's that
as always it's the lawyers who are the
real heroes that are looking out for
those in need
eat it doctors and nurses now of course
part of what got us here is a failure to
understand the exponential growth of
viruses and since most of us have some
extra time on our hands hashtag
quarantine life now would be a great
time to learn how to think through all
the kinds of challenging problems
including growth functions and you can
do that with brilliant brilliant is an
app with a huge library of courses that
will help you build quantitative skills
in math science and computer science
with fun and challenging interactive
explorations whether you want to
understand the fundamentals of coding
stretcher analytical muscles with logic
puzzles or dust off your high school
geometry skills to help your quarantine
kids with their quarantine homework
brilliant has a course that can help you
reach your goal with courses for all
skill levels brilliant is built for ages
10 to 110 the app offers short lessons
divided into different math science and
computer science subjects that explain
concepts and principles that you can use
to solve problems with schools cancelled
for the foreseeable future brilliant is
a great way for students to keep their
skills sharp and if you're a college
student looking to get a leg up on the
competition
brilliant has everything you need to
level up your stem knowledge best of all
brilliant is absolutely fun there's
nothing worse than listening to hours of
boring lectures by an old teacher
standing at a chalkboard but
let's you learn by doing which is
scientifically proven to be the most
effective way to master any new skill
within brilliants library you'll find
courses and topics like calculus and
linear algebra and math that applies to
trading in finance
you'll also find courses on
gravitational physics at astronomy and
machine learning one of my favorite
courses is logic the logic course covers
liar and truth teller riddles logical
fallacies machine logic and even some
strategic game theory learning the
principles of logic is essential for
lawyers doctors and nurses but believe
me I know the thought of cracking open a
logic textbook makes you want to run for
the hills and that's where brilliance
method makes the biggest difference
brilliant clever and fun videos will
show you puzzles and riddles and give
you the tools you need to solve them you
can sign up and start learning for free
today at brilliant org slash legal eagle
and the first 200 people who sign up
will also get 20% off their annual
subscription so just go to brilliant dot
org slash legal eagle or just click the
link in the description to get 20% off
of your subscription to brilliant plus
clicking on the link really helps out
this channel so do you agree with my
analysis leave your objections in the
comments and check out this playlist
over here where I explore all the other
legal issues of the day like how the
u.s. botched its response to Cove in 19
so click on this playlist and I'll see
you in court